good morning and welcome to the meeting
of this cabinet my name is Susan Junaid
and I'm the chairman of this meeting and
I welcome you here today
moving forward we've got the apologies
for absence have we received any
apologies uh for today's meeting
non-received
and do we have any members who have any
interests that they wish to declare
before this meeting
I thank you chairman uh I wish to
declare an interest on item four on the
defibrillators I'm a former chairman of
the napkin defibrillator group and I
said at the council I have been a
recipient of the effect of such a device
and I wish to declare an interest in
that I am a director of the heart of
England
solar panel Farm that's just on the
outskirts of Stratford so if there is
any debate I will not take part in any
debate because I am a director of that
farm thank you
moving on on
the minutes of the last meeting I have
asked whether these should be noted or
confirmed but we they are to be
confirmed
are you all in agreement on that do you
all accept that they should be confirmed
thank you very much indeed
moving on we've got the party which is
the matters to be referred to council
and we have two notices of motion that
come under this one part four as is
noted uh councilor Rock declared an
interest on which is on the provision of
community Public Access defibrillators
on new developments we have to consider
a motion in respect of this provision
and I call on councilor Coles to
introduce the item and to move a
recommendation and then I will call for
a second afterwards
uh thank you chair
um
the cabinet has been asked by Council to
consider the motion uh in respect
provision of community Public Access
defibrillators on new developments this
is presented to the council meeting on
the 24th of April of this year the
report is within your papers and there
are three options open to the cabinet
um consider the motion at the meeting
without benefit of report from officers
to fur consideration of the moment
motion to a way to report from officers
or to refer the motion to overview and
scrutiny
um I move that we
take option b to defer the consideration
of the motion until we have a report
from officers
and can I call on a second uh
is there a second
okay
and um
is everyone in agreement with that that
number B with B it was to take it
Forward awaiting a report is undertaken
councilor Rock
um having declared an interest in it
it's clear I've got some knowledge about
about the system
um it's just that the scope of the
report I'm just wonder if we can point
out to officers it needs a fairly wide
scope because the ambulance service and
the Health Service have changed the way
they deal with this and since my day
when it was started a number of years
ago
so I think it needs to have a fairly
wide remit to find out what the
implications for this Council and
communities are because it has
interactions with those other services
that's just a point for noting really
so that point is noted but the
recommendation is that we all agree that
um that it should go forward for a
report thank you very much indeed
we now move on to the notice of motion
um the impact of solar farm development
and this is to consider um a motion that
came to the Council on the 24th of April
I invoked councilor coucher to introduce
this item and if he could he feels it
correct that to move the recommendation
and then I will call for public
information that I think Stephen norie
wants to speak for three minutes and
counselor passingum also wants to to
make a statement to the cabinet so I
invite counselor capture to remove to
introduce the item to start with
thank you very much Cher
um clearly this is a very important
matter which is having a an impact on
Stratford district and the impact of
solar farm development
whilst many of us are very much in favor
of sustainable energy and solar Farms
are an important component of that we're
also mindful of landscape and also the
quality of
agricultural land
there are three options available to us
um one to consider the content of the
motion at the meeting without the
beneficial report for the officers on
the implications of this
second one is clearly to defer
consideration pending a report from
officers and see is to refer the motion
to the oversue overview and scrutiny
committee as I've said this is a very
important issue and we believe that it
would be very important to have a proper
report before we make a final decision
on this and so I'm recommending that we
support option b
can I call for uh Stephen Nori to come
forward and give his statement for three
minutes
thank you uh here representing Stratford
climate action we know that in future
climate breakdown is going to lead to
increasingly serious disruption of our
food supply as temperature zones shift
extreme weather increases and invasive
pests and diseases multiply this is
already influencing Rising food prices
today it's therefore a right to worry
about future food production
however looking at the whole system
rather than just one field there's no
good reason to oppose solar Farms on
grounds of food production
solar Farms are necessary to limit the
impact of climate breakdown and
agriculture even the cpre's recent
report on rooftop solar admits that
solar Farms will be needed to meet our
1.5 degree targets
thus although land used for solar Farms
may not directly produce food it can be
seen as an investment in the food
productivity of other land
we're clearly on the cusp of a great
transformation of our land and Food
Systems we know we need more onshore
Renewables at forestation and rewilding
we know less land intensive food
production techniques can compensate for
this plant-based food indoor farming
Precision fermentation and so on
Renewables look likely to take up only
around half the British land mass
currently devoted to golf courses or
0.99 to 1.4 percent of the land in
England according to the CBRE
any food production from this land
predominantly grade 3B can easily be
counter-balanced by cutting back on
animal agriculture which we know is an
extraordinarily unproductive use of land
for food or biofuels which currently
take up 77 more percent more percent
more land than solar Farms whilst being
much less productive in terms of energy
asked landscape having attended planning
committee debates over solar Farms I'd
say that this is already amply
considered in decision making it's
generally recognized that solar Farms
should be situated appropriately
concealed by planting and so on
councilors sometimes vote against
proposals for that reason
my own view is that the impression these
Farms will drastically damage the
experience of the countryside is
inflated
where Farms have been approved I think
this is not because the countryside has
lacked protection or not been taken
seriously but because enough councilors
have recognized that the impact on the
countryside and the lives of local
people will be too small to override the
benefits of the proposals additional
protections seem unnecessary
whilst traffic climate action supports
solar panels in the built environment
there are good economic reasons why
solar Farms are springing up on farmland
and not rooftops at the moment and it's
not clear that the district council has
the powers to alter that situation
looking at the council's most recent
update on its climate Action Program
it's clear that a lot of planned actions
aren't moving forward at the pace
required probably due in part to lack of
council capacity
for instance the motion doesn't offer
any examples of what other councils have
done to encourage Urban solar we'd
prefer the council to be building
officer capacity rather than taking it
up with actions which may not offer much
Prospect of success so as it stands I'm
afraid I don't think the motion is very
useful for Council climate action thank
you
thank you thank you now I've got um
councilor passing and wants to come and
also make a statement
morning everyone
right I also have a declaration of
Interest I am a voluntary director and
investor of Heart of England Community
energy solar farm
which is a community benefit society and
as such any profits are donated to local
charities
um
the solar farm covers 60 Acres along the
Ulster road on the way out of Stratford
and it produces enough electricity for 4
500 homes in in Stratford the whole 60
Acres was planted as a wildflower Meadow
six years ago and if anybody goes down
there it's in in the middle of summer
it's a fantastic environment to be in
the trees and the hedges were preserved
and retained and they're managed at the
moment for wildlife
according to the wildlife warranty
Wildlife trust Wildlife is disappearing
at an alarming rate
some are calling it the next mass
extinction and the threat of climate
catastrophe is a constant worry
so
we live in an emergency and therefore we
need to decarbonize our energy way more
quickly than we are doing now
yes to solar roofs on car Parks but we
need far more than that
just 0.1 percent of UK land area is
taken up by solar farms at the moment
and this could increase to 0.3 percent
if we produce all the solar Farms we
need golf courses uh there's various
figures for it but Steven's figure was
about one percent I think of the of the
land is covered by that so far more than
will be used by by solar Farms
as Stephen has said pasture is a most
inefficient source of food production
yet yet it occupies
28.7 of UK land
converting a tiny part of this to
Cellular would meet the projected needs
of solar power for the whole country
whilst having only a minute effect on
food production
as a Rough Guide beef farming uses six
times more land than arable farming to
produce the same amount of protein and
calories and livestock is reckoned to be
responsible for 14 of greenhouse gas
emissions
so
solar Farms are already regulated they
have to produce environmental impact
assessments like everything else all the
other planning applications and they're
usually time limited to 20 or 25 years
so there's no need for additional
regulations on cellular Farms
we are in a climate emergency and an
ecological emergency
solar Farms can make a contribution to
mitigating both
they can do this by enhancing the
countryside and without affecting food
production
thank you councilor passingum I know
that you've also read the carbon brief
report because I recognize quite a lot
of the the facts from it so thank you
very much indeed on that one
um counselor coucher you moved the
original
recommendation I call for a second do
you want to make any comments at all on
that oh you're happy that we I moved to
a secondary
okay anybody that wants to Second the
most the this is that a report will be
undertaken
um by the officers and it will come to
the next available meeting of the
cabinet are you happy about that all
agreed
to come from a concert
so just to be clear who who seconded
councilor Curtis okay
just to be clear and this will now come
to the next available meeting of the
cabinet are you all in agreement
okay that's no dissent on that one it's
all agreed thank you
Part B now is matters for decision by
the cabinet and the first one is the
Constitution which is agreed terms of
reference and this is to consider a
report
that outlines
the climate change in the house housing
investment panel this is the next one I
thought the constitution in terms of
reference where the next was the next
one
okay
okay item six related to that is the
climate change of okay the terms of
reference on appointments to the climate
change panel and the housing investment
panel I see what you you this is so the
report outlines the changes to the
Constitution following the annual
council meeting and what it is is that
we do need to have for example new
people on the climate change panel and
also how people on the housing
investment panel and um the
recommendation if accepted
um are notes that the the membership of
the climate change panel will be myself
as portfolio holder for climate change
um the portfolio holder for the South
worship plan Advisory Group councilor
Rock the chairman of the overview and
scrutiny committee councilor Crump and
I've nominated Council pertigella and
counselor petrovich and the leader of
the main opposition group has nominated
councilor Stan Stanley and the leader of
the minority opposition group will be
requested to nominate a member of the
climate change panel as well
so the on the housing investment panel
um the amendments are designed to
reflect changes to the portfolios so
it's a committee of the cabinet so
members have to be drawn from the
cabinet and recommendation three if
supported will then see councilors
Junaid Curtis and Coles appointed to the
housing investment panel
the options available to us are to
approve or to decide on alternatives
are you happy to accept the
recommendation to approve
how are you coming counselor calls any
comments anybody else got any comments
are you happy to to accept the
recommendation okay
sorry is there a formal seconder to that
counselor culture thank you very much
indeed
all agreed
agreed thank you
the next item seven is to receive a
report that outlines the year-end
performance achieved during 2023 to 2023
monitoring of the council plan and key
performance indicators I'm presenting
this in this item to you
um which is the agreed 65 actions that
were agreed for 2022-23 and of which one
item is no longer applicable and that
was the development of Eastern Place
initiative the others are other 64 tasks
are all reported on in the appendix full
details are there there were 20 uh key
performance indicated that monitored the
performance 16 of these were related to
the council plan objectives and four to
corporate health indicators and the the
report goes on to show which of those
targets were achieved and which ones
were not not achieved
the full details are presented in the
appendix appendix one appendix 2 and
then appendix 3 shows the dashboard
presenting the time series analysis now
the um of the the conclusions and the
reason for this recommendation
um going forward is that 50 of the
council plan actions were achieved three
percent were partially achieved 65 were
have been achieved but obviously there
were others that were not achieved now
have have I got anybody that wants to
make any comments
um to um that a bit and then I will ask
for a second
chairman I just wanted to make the point
in relation to the council plan actions
particularly the the 64 tasks which have
been tasked for delivery actually takes
us up to the 30th of September 2023
because we the current council plan is
up until that particular day before we
then ask Council to consider for the
next iteration of the council plan so
effectively over two-thirds of the
period through I know it's couched as a
a annual monetary report but in relation
to the council plan actions we do have
18 months and that's why some of the
actions haven't actually been delivered
as yet
accepting that 12 weren't achieved by
the Target States within that approved
council plan action plan
could I ask if any any of the counselors
want to particularly make any comments
about the performance plan both the
going back in the past over the last
year and then going forward as well
councilor Curtis
thank you
um
was obviously I understand Mr buckland's
points that we still are in this council
plan I think the report does raise a
number of concerns about the performance
of the council under the previous
leadership
and this report I think does suggest
perhaps
that we could have a better approach to
monitoring and addressing slippage in
the objectives
I think we have a different
perspective to that of the outgoing
Administration in relation to what
matters most to improving residents
lives and as this is a partly
retrospective report and we are early in
our new political cycle we can only look
at how to improve performance and ensure
that our promises are delivered going
forward thank you
would you like to make any comments at
this point
foreign
contrast to what council curtiser just
said I would actually like to applaud
the previous administration because
there was lots here of very important
things that have been achieved and
moving forwards we wait to see how
you're going to continue on that level
of um well really outstanding
achievements there that we have before
us thank you
are there any other people that want to
make any comments the only comments that
I want to make is that I I do hope
counselor Crump would you like to come
in at this point Thank you cancer is it
okay if I do it is part of my osc report
because we did consider it it's it's on
Friday so I'll just if it's okay I'll
mention it as part of the report rather
than and separately I'll view any issue
as well it might be useful if it's
specifically to this performance report
to have it now yeah oh
um right then
unfortunately the machines plugged in
now so apologies are slightly like I've
got stuck in traffic in an accident
fortunately nobody injured um
right we we looked at the performance
report
um
and we felt that the committee would
continue to to monitor this
um items that came out consistently were
resourcing recruitment and retention
and I think we have have seen that
performance had been affected by staff
vacancies and sickness and I think um
that's been acknowledged so I think that
um we as the security committee would
ask you to ensure that is monitored
because obviously staff are our key
resource our our biggest asset so
therefore we need to ensure that if the
council was going to perform properly it
needs to have the right staff in the
right place so so I think that was that
was the main one we also spoke about the
kprm broadband and that led to
discussions around issues with BD UK in
the provision of full fiber across the
district and the impact that is open on
certain communities
and we also touch brief the
um about the planning policy work safe
Works your local plan
um and
um
yeah we will watch and wonder how what
will happen with his safe thoughts your
local plan with two new administrations
at um Warwick and Stratford so
um that was the main things around about
about performance but we do think that
[Music]
um
Staffing is is vital to ensure we've got
resources in place to deliver because we
are providing resources such as the
climate change money Council Curtis
aren't we
um unfortunately passes
um and so therefore if that money's
going to be used and used widely we need
office and support to make sure that's
spent so that's just one example thank
you
um can I thank you that that was very
constructive
um and making sure that we do have
Staffing levels and resources is is
quite key and counselor Rock
uh yes I just wanted to comment on all
the previous speakers
um are all correct in their different
ways but I think what we're interested
is going forward
as a well-known quality management tool
here things gone right things gone wrong
uh so we should focus on both and get
those as learning points for how we
construct and deal with the the plan
going forward and indeed the balance
between here and the Autumn so I think
that they're all valid points uh let's
let's let's make the best of our
experience
thank you and um the only other thing
that I would like to comment on is
making sure that we
um address the issues around
um the the Home Choice plus and disabled
facilities grants and homelessness and
and it but this is subject to uh other
reports that will come forward it's it's
a particular
um interest of mine to make sure that we
are addressing
um you know our relationship with the
Housing Association and our
um our social the provision of
affordable homes but that's uh for
future but it was just one thing that I
thought I would raise at this point
um if
counselor
Johnson Lorraine counselor grow cup
thank you um Casa junid um I was just
looking at uh priority three responding
to the climate change emergency
obviously this has been done in context
of waste collection which comes out of
my portfolio I'd like to see the kpis in
the coming up year being broadened out
to other sort of climate change
responders the climate change merger not
in just how the bins are being collected
if that's right
thank you and just to be clear that on
climate change I've kept that as part of
my portfolio because that's something I
feel very very strongly about and I've
got a lot of expertise I'm I'm hoping to
be able to contribute to that in future
um so have we got any other
um any other comments uh on the year-end
performance report
then we call for a second of the uh does
anybody want to move the recommendation
and then can we call for a second uh
going forward
I propose we note this report
and a second
counselor Coles
are we all in agreement
Now we move on to another report uh
slightly more
um
different which is the procurements of
complex needs service for vulnerable
residents and this is a procurement of a
service that we have to consider today
there is a report councilor Coles you're
able to introduce this item and then
move to a recommendation please
thank you chair okay uh this report is
has come to the committee to seek
approval to undertake a procurement
exercise in line with Constitution
standing orders and to make provision
for the government's rough sleeping
initiative
there is funding from central government
from this scheme which is ring fence to
provision and must be spent
the existing scheme started in 2017 and
ends at the end of August this year and
provides support to some residents who
are among the most vulnerable across our
district
the report seeks approval to go to
market and procure the provision of this
service
um
we are not at this point seeking to
award a contract or allocate the funding
and at this stage at the moment because
we haven't gone to Tender we don't know
which providers may wish to undertake
the work
um it's the initiative has been
announced as having a four-year lifespan
but only at the moment only two years
have been allocated therefore the
procurement will be for the first two
years with an option to extend for
another two if the government funding is
forthcoming and guaranteed so we don't
commit to funding we're not actually
receiving
if we decide not to go support the
procurement progress progress a bigger
pardon or defer then there is a risk
that these September start date May well
be compromised and that would be to the
detriment of those vulnerable residents
therefore can I
recommend that this procurement process
is approved by this committee
okay thank you and just to be clear that
that is
um the on page one it's recommendations
one and two and for those that have got
the papers in front of them uh do we
have anybody else or seconded to that
um that that
motion and that recommendation and
anybody else that wants to come in
counselor Wally Huggins yes this is
um just as an aside really I think that
overviewing scrutiny committee meeting
on Friday it became apparent that those
perhaps a lack of knowledge regarding
the complex needs of Our rough
um of Our rough sleepers and I'm
wondering if officers could be moved
simultaneously to what the decision made
today that we get out a briefing paper
to all councilors so that they have a
better and and a more in-depth
understanding of why these needs of
these uh of our roof sleepers are or a
segment of them are are so very
complicated and are you know the needs
for this this type of investment and
also critically why the investments in
the long term will most necessarily be
work be worth the investment thank you
that's all I really wanted to say and I
obviously commend the opportunity that
the government central government is
giving with this with this grant thank
you
I came to the cause I think that sounds
a reasonable I think are you happy with
that and cancer certainly your officers
are happy with that as a recommendation
yes okay thank you thank you
so we've got the recommendations in
front of us um did I see a second to
that recommendation
councilor grow cuts anybody else want to
make any comments
then are you all in agreement
thank you
moving on to part C which is the issues
arising from the overview and scrutiny
committee
comes counselor thank you Council doing
it um
we had the meeting on Friday and I've
I've given you and councilor rocker a
synopsis it wasn't too brief but I
thought it was quite comprehensive to
talk about the issues that we went
through as a new committee with lots of
new members on there
smiling shiny face bright and Keen
um
and that's just me no
um they um it was the first one
um we had a pre-median to go through
setting the ground rules about
attendance positively contributing being
prepared having focused questions
because we really want to focus this
year on on proper ovum scrutiny um not
saying we didn't do proper English
reading but we've reflected we think
things can be improved
so we we talked about various issues we
had bromford come in a following a
notice a motion
um that was done by cancer curses at
December's council meeting and various
issues around repairs customer contact
Time listening something associated
affordability and availability of a
housing so lots of issues that we've
discussed and
um we will be circulating the
presentation which seemed to show some
positive Improvement in their services
and um teams have some good examples of
best practice that
um the Housing Association task and
finish group that we're going to be set
up
um would be looking at and considering
um
and one of the things that was key
um is communication as we all know
um some
vegetable landlords communication is is
difficult and I did quite an example
with with that a very close relative of
mine who was having problems and the
left hand didn't know what the right
hand was doing and so it wasn't a great
so hopefully we'll the Tuscan finish
group will pick up on these
um
so that one has been
it's created up the housing Associated
testing finish group uh as as discussed
by based on the previous housing notice
of motion we've got three volunteers
already which is which is good
um press Gangnam might be the word but
we'll settle for volunteers so uh
um we will have a couple more and we're
going to uh tap into offices when needed
uh
we've discussed the performance CRM
report which we've discussed complex
needs to report
um we were slightly disappointed to have
the paper on the day of the meeting
um but obviously it's early in the
community side or so so suddenly I would
give them around the light production
report and
um
but as the scrutiny committee we feel
it's harder to receive reports in a
timely fashion to properly scrutinize
government decisions and and you know to
be honest to be fair I did raise it I
did mention that if the previous
administration had done the same thing I
would have been critical as well so you
know to be consistent
and we do know I think in July's cabinet
there's at least 12 potentially 14 items
on there
15 I've just been told higher higher
so I think that is really we need the
information is promptly so we can look
at them and then potentially if there's
any you know things to call in or
whatever not um but like to but again
better decisions are based on
um members having time to prepare to
look at them so better scrutiny rather
than better decisions I think councilor
Curtis was looking at me there um so I
think he's right here better better
scrutiny is he's got more time to prefer
um so if that could be noted uh we'll
talk about the performance or the
complex needs I totally agree with
councilor only Huggins about the
explanation around the complex needs
about this small extremely vulnerable
cohort we have
in in the district so again if we can
explain that and the good news is
obviously it's been funded so it's not
coming from
The District Council Office but again we
need to make sure the money is spent
wisely so I think that was a bit and
then we've talked about the work plan
and we'll be looking at Future items uh
housing the housing Tuscan finish group
we would like integrated care board to
come in to discuss various issues
um I think we mentioned up a light on
the budget review of Alan Badger and
Stratford hospital and again
um as we fund Park funds Shakespeare's
England we would look for them to come
back on a regular basis and then after
the meeting we had a debrief to see some
learning points what we can do and to
make sure that members are preferred to
meetings and to command with questions
and ideas
so positive meeting two and a half hours
which was good well done I'm sure it's
only clear incidents that we were in
time because councilor Ralph wasn't
there but I'm sure that must be a
coincidence but I'm sure cats are off
would would wouldn't want me say that
because we see um just keep us on the
straighter now so and it would be good
to have her back
um because we've got quite a few new but
very keen characters but the cohort of
experience counselors is quite small so
one being absent um
makes a bit of a difference so lots of
keen people so thank you very much um
but like I say um if we can have the
reports as soon as possible like I say
not too much of an issue it was only a
small report
um but it it didn't help so thank you
can I thank you Council it was nice to
see the continuation of you and in the
role from the from the previous uh
Administration so uh with somebody with
the experience there which is useful and
and your points are noted and um yes
that um will be taken on board very most
definitely
um the um
I said just um and moving forward you
know please one thing that I would
appreciate is if you feel that it's uh
that I could add to anything on the on
the housing uh review because I I have
quite a lot of casework in my area it
would be up to you to invite me but um
if you feel that I could be of help then
that's uh that the offer is there
we're moving on now to Cabinet
committees and there were none to report
on during this period and then Part D is
the unblock items now for the items in
this section the reports and
recommendations will be approved on
block unless a request has been made to
me at the start of the meeting for the
item to be discussed I've had no
requests for the any items to be
discussed so if unless there's any
anybody wants to make any comment now
um I remove that they be taken on block
and does do we have a do we need a
secondary for that no in that case do
you all agree that they're taken and
recorded on block thank you
so that covers the leadership the
cabinet work program and the climate
change panel
Part F is other matters 11
urgent business and we haven't had no
um
yes
sorry
um I just had a comment on the climate
change panel minutes if I may
um you didn't raise that with me at the
beginning
um is it you know so is a
it's it's
a little bit of leeway given that it's
your our first meeting okay it was
simply to say that I
um looking at Mr Thomas's comments about
the difficulties of navigating the
process of contributing to the panel
I do agree with those comments and I
think we need to ensure that it is much
easier for residents to engage with
democracy and we are already taking some
steps to improve Clarity Clarity and
transparency
um I also agree with this point about
speed of progress and his remarks about
need to influence County Council and
national government
but I anticipate that having a dedicated
responsibility for climate change at the
highest level in the council with you as
as part of your leaders portfolio will
enable us to accelerate change in that
area thank you
and it is worth noting that we're now
going to as a council have a dedicated
officer within the council as well which
is I think very much to be welcomed
councilor up do you want to make any
comments at this moment uh it's on the
cabinet work program Madam chairman
okay we're still on that again you we
did you didn't notify but I'll give you
some leeway uh well it's it's um a
question of record really all
clarification on page 38 it lists the
portfolio holders uh but I'll see it go
forward to August 23.
um I don't want to seem like a pedant
than previous people
but um is that sort of correct or should
that be clarified
chairman just a clarification then
please so this was a couple of world
program that was published on the 28th
of April 2023 and and absolutely correct
as at that particular time prior to the
elections thank you
as a matter of clarification
um so um that those were those all
agreed on block Hall agreed great and
then moving on to other matters urgent
business we have no urgent business
then I um the next meeting of the
cabinet is scheduled to take place on
Monday the 3rd of July when I can assure
you there will be a lot more business to
discuss so thank you very much indeed
for your attendance today uh I declare
the meeting closed
thank you